y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento el sumario de
temas que tenemos para el programa de
hoy vamos a hablar de los anuncios
hechos en eeuu a lo largo de esta semana
comenzamos hablando de las vacunaciones
en las grandes cadenas de farmacias
asimismo también anunciaron la
adquisición de nuevos lotes de vacunas y
posiblemente sean aprobadas otras
vacunas para que entren a ser inoculadas
entre la población estadounidense
también daremos un vistazo a cómo está
la situación general en este país en
unos minutos con nuestra corresponsal en
la ciudad de nueva york
mamen sala en medio de muchas
controversias perú comenzó también su
plan de vacunación muchos ciudadanos no
confían en las vacunas en este país y no
desean ser inoculados a pesar de esto el
país suramericano va contra el tiempo
con este proceso de inmunización
mientras también los casos siguen
aumentando los fallecidos también siguen
aumentando
y también pues siguen allí algunas
restricciones se mantienen sobre todo en
lima en el área metropolitana y en el
puerto del callao en minutos vamos a
conversar con francisco zacarías el
corresponsal de france 24 en la capital
peruana y vamos a conocer detalles de
los avances del plan de vacunación en
argentina uno de los primeros países en
nuestra región que comenzó a inmunizar
pero el avance ha sido muy lento y ha
generado todo tipo de críticas hacia el
gobierno críticas que también han
recaído en el hecho de que este país
solamente le está apostando a un tipo de
vacuna en estas circunstancias vale la
pena y así lo han demostrado algunos
países no depender de una sola
trataremos de resolver esa inquietud con
natalio cost hoy nuestro periodista en
la ciudad de buenos aires- pues estos
son algunos de los temas hay muchos más
pero comencemos ya les decía yo que
vamos a comenzar entonces primero con
una actualización del avance de los
planes de vacunación en el continente
americano estas son las cifras del 11 de
febrero del 2021
eeuu lidera en el continente con más
de 46 millones 300 mil dosis de vacunas
aplicadas en todo el territorio le sigue
brasil con más de 4 millones también
está chile con 1 millón 600 mil dosis
aplicadas y canadá con un millón 190 mil
dosis ya también inoculadas méxico llega
al cierre de esta semana con 725 mil 400
dosis inoculadas argentinas que es el
país del que hablaremos más adelante
supera las 500 72 mil dosis nada mal
pero es que argentina fue uno de los que
primero empezó le sigue perú con más de
32 mil dosis este país lleva solamente
unos cuantos días vacunando y había una
división de opiniones como lo decíamos
entre los ciudadanos frente a este
proceso de inmunización no muy lejos de
allí
bolivia supera ya las 10 mil 167 dosis
todos estos son datos de hour world in
data y también cerramos este reporte
contándoles que colombia uruguay
paraguay venezuela y surinam y también
las 2 guyanas todos en américa del sur
no han comenzado todavía
planes de vacunación se unen a esta
lista también nicaragua y honduras en
centroamérica
ya lo decíamos eeuu se lidera la
vacunación en américa y a nivel mundial
también con más de 46 millones de
personas inoculadas rápidez territorios
abarcados y masificación son las
premisas de este plan de vacunación y no
es para menos porque es que eeuu es el
país que más ha afectado la pandemia a
nivel mundial tiene más de 27 millones
de casos confirmados y más de 479 mil
personas han fallecido allí vamos a
conocer más detalles con la mensa la
nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de
nueva york mamen del comienzo podrá
preguntarle sobre uno de estos planes
que pronto va a entrar en marcha y en
eeuu para hacer aún más masiva la
vacunación y consiste en vacunación a
través de las grandes cadenas de
farmacias y también una vacunación libre
a partir de abril es decir que la
persona que quiera acceder a la vacuna
simplemente va a la compra y se inyectan
de nos más detalles
sí desde hoy mismo ya se puede
administrar la vacuna contra el cob y 19
en farmacias distribuidas en 17 estados
del país
el plan arranca con una distribución de
un millón de vacunas en al menos a seis
mil 500 farmacias pero se espera poco a
poco ampliar ese número hasta las 40.000
de momento estas vacunas se van a
administrar a los grupos de riesgo
siguiendo un poco el plan de vacunación
que se ha estipulado a nivel nacional y
luego por parte de cada estado pero
según la máxima autoridad sanitaria del
país el doctor anthony fauci para abril
cualquier persona que lo desee podrá
acceder a una vacuna llegando a esa
inmunidad colectiva de la que tanto se
ha hablado para que os hagáis una idea
ahora mismo en eeuu se han distribuido
ya 63 millones de vacunas y hay 43
millones de personas que ya han recibido
al menos una o dos dosis eso significa
un 13% de la población estadounidense
también también está previsto para final
de mes que tanto el gobierno como la fd
se reúnan para determinar si le permiten
el ingreso
mercado estadounidense a otra vacuna es
decir otra otra farmacéutica entraría a
competir allí contra moderna y fisher
que se sabe al respecto
si este próximo 26 de febrero
los expertos de la sda que es la agencia
del medicamento estadounidenses se
reunirán para valorar la vacuna para
valorar la aprobación la m el uso de
emergencia de la vacuna de johnson and
johnson y si todo va bien pocos días
después de eeuu tendría ya tres vacunas
para hacer frente al cob y 19 la de
facer la de moderna y la de johnson and
johnson esta última se trata de una
vacuna que se administra en una sola
dosis además se espera que su
distribución sea mucho más sencilla
porque no necesita conservarse a tan
bajas temperaturas como por ejemplo la
de facer y esto permitirá llegar a las
zonas rurales donde ese sistema de
mantenimiento o eso sea es el almacenaje
a tan baja temperatura es más complicado
no además también la vacuna de johnson
and johnson tiene una efectividad de tan
sólo un 66% en general y de un 85 por
ciento en las enfermedades más graves
desde luego muy buenas noticias pero eso
sí los expertos insisten en que
de que la mayoría de la población
empiece a vacunarse de que los casos de
contagio estén bajando hay que seguir
manteniendo esas medidas anti kobe es
decir distanciamiento social y
mascarilla en todo momento también
entonces tenemos múltiples vacunas y
también múltiples lugares para acceder a
ella pero entonces el mercado necesita
que les suministren vacunas rápidamente
que ha hecho el gobierno en torno a la
compra de los lotes que van a llegar
próximamente
si el presidente de joe biden ha
anunciado que ya se han cerrado los
acuerdos para la adquisición de 200
millones de vacunas más se comprarán 100
millones a modernas y otros 100 millones
a la farmacéutica pfiezer esto qué
significa pues bien que para finales de
julio a eeuu podría tener ya y
administrar 300 millones de vacunas
recordemos que la población en eeuu es
de 330 millones de personas
eso sí como os decía las autoridades
insisten en que hay que seguir
manteniendo el distanciamiento social y
la buena noticia también es que a estas
200 millones de vacunas que se van a
comprar ahora a modernas y a facer se
sumarán muy pronto 100 millones en
cuanto se apruebe por parte de la sda de
la vacuna de johnson and johnson la
farmacéutica ha dicho que ha pactado con
eeuu esos 100 millones de dosis antes
del mes de julio en la pregunta que le
hago a todos los corresponsales
recordemos cuáles son las medidas que
están todavía vigentes en eeuu cuáles
son las restricciones
sobre todo cómo está la situación en
esas zonas que han sido las más
afectadas ej el estado de california el
estado de texas florida y el estado de
nueva york donde usted se encuentra
bueno aquí en eeuu como sabéis cada
estado opera de una manera muy diferente
así que hay que tener os habría que ir
uno por uno analizando los pero
centrándonos en los estados que digamos
la peor situación tienen en estos
momentos iríamos a california donde
acaba de superar a nueva york en el
número de muertes por kobe 19 esto no
son buenas noticias recordemos que en
nueva york fue el epicentro de la
pandemia en un principio por eso en
algunas zonas como la baja california
durante las celebraciones de este san
valentín van a permanecer los bares y
los restaurantes cerrados en florida el
gobernador republicano ha criticado
fuertemente esa intención que tiene job
aidan de establecer unas restricciones
de viaje dice que es inconstitucional e
injusto en texas a los contagios se
están disminuyendo como muchas otras
partes del país y se agarran a ese dato
positivo para que su gobernador anuncie
que va a empezar a levantarse las
restricciones eso sí con mucha cautela
algo que también está ocurriendo aquí en
nueva york donde a partir de hoy vuelven
a abrirlos
antes en el interior se podrán servir a
cenas o comidas con un 25% de la
capacidad y si todo va bien y el número
de contagios continúa descendiendo el
gobernador andrew como ya ha anunciado
que a partir del 23 de febrero se
abrirán los grandes estadios eso sí
solamente con un 10 por ciento de
asistencia manteniendo siempre la
distancia social mascarillas
obligatorias y habrá que presentar una
prueba negativa con 72 horas de
antelación antes de ingresar a este a
este evento también muchas gracias por
este reporte esta actualización de la
situación en eeuu mamen salen
formándonos desde la ciudad de nueva
york hablamos ahora del presidente de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador quien
volvió a presidir la habitual rueda de
prensa matutina conocida como la
mañanera después de estar dos semanas
confinados y en tratamiento por haber
contraído kobe 19 pese a haber ya
padecido esta enfermedad no cambió su
opinión sobre el kobe 19 y anticipó que
no va a usar mascarilla y que va a
prontamente a retomar los viajes al
interior de la república
un regreso con el mismo discurso pese a
haberse contagiado de kobe 19 andrés
manuel lópez obrador no cambiara su
postura frente a la pandemia en su
primera aparición pública en dos semanas
advirtió que volverá a realizar giras
por el país y que no utilizará
mascarillas quienes todo es voluntario
lo más importante es la libertad y cada
quien debe de asumir
su responsabilidad desde el inicio de la
pandemia el mandatario mexicano se ha
rehusado a seguir varias de las
recomendaciones de las autoridades
sanitarias y ha asistido a eventos
públicos en los que suele abrazarse con
ciudadanos además se ha mostrado
reticente a adoptar restricciones más
duras pese al repunte de los contagios
en el país porque me contagié porque
esto que trabajaba
cómo
millones de mexicanos una realidad que
lleva a múltiples trabajadores
informales a mantener sus actividades
pese a las restricciones en ciudad de
méxico cuando realmente es cuestión
laboral pues solamente nos queda
cuidarnos porque realmente también por
temas de economía no podemos
a quedarnos en casa no olvidas que luego
no hay ni para comer en serio no lo
hagamos muy difícil
el gobierno mexicano se planteó la
ambiciosa meta de vacunar a todos los
adultos mayores del país para finales de
marzo para avanzar con ese plan lópez
obrador confirmó que esperan la llegada
de un millón de dosis de la vacuna de
astrazéneca producida en india antes del
fin de semana actual
antes de continuar con otros temas
recordemos cómo está el panorama mundial
en cuanto al avance de la pandemia del
cob el 19 porque pese a que la
vacunación y el autocuidado se mantiene
la emergencia sanitaria a nivel mundial
también persiste veamos entonces los
números de acuerdo al conteo de la
universidad johns hopkins tenemos al día
de hoy 107 millones 969 mil 754 casos de
contagio de kobe 19 en todo el mundo
personas recuperadas 60 millones 439 mil
42 personas los fallecidos ya alcanzan
los 2 millones 377 mil 373 mil 733
personas mientras que las personas
vacunadas a nivel mundial ya rondan los
160 millones
y ahora nos vamos hasta perú este país
dio inicio al plan de vacunación contra
el cob y 19 en medio de divisiones entre
los ciudadanos en cuanto al proceso de
inmunización según algunos sondeos en
ese país casi la mitad de la población
se opone a la vacunación en esta primera
fase que ha comenzado esta semana será
el personal de salud el que reciba las
dosis de la vacuna scinopharm que es
desarrollada en china y de las cuales
pero ya recibió las primeras 300.000
dosis
un carnet y una sonrisa encubierta un
recuerdo de una jornada histórica en la
que ellos el personal de salud de
primera línea de batalla contra el
comité 19 son los protagonistas pero
comenzó en lima la capital su vacunación
contra el cob y 19 en una etapa inicial
que tiene como objetivo inocular a un
millón de personas entre profesionales
sanitarios militares y policías me
parecía muy lejos
la vacuna para realizar este proceso
y me parece un sueño
y comienza un proceso que llena de
esperanza al segundo país de américa con
la mayor tasa de mortalidad por cada
100.000 habitantes por el nuevo
coronavirus sólo superado por eeuu los
lotes de la vacuna ya partieron fuera de
lima a otras regiones como huánuco una
de las zonas más castigadas por el
hobbit 19 en el horizonte una siguiente
fase para vacunar a 5,3 millones de
adultos mayores con enfermedades
preexistentes se ha empezado por vacunar
a nivel nacional todos los
establecimientos que cuentan con una
unidad de cuidados intensivos todo el
personal asistencial del establecimiento
el que tiene que ver con contacto
directo con los pacientes se vacuna
primero hay alivio para el comienzo de
la vacunación siendo perú el sexto país
de sudamérica en dar inicio a este
proceso
la mala noticia llega desde la
asociación nacional de periodistas de
perú que afirma que en 10 meses
108 reporteros han perdido de la vida a
causa del cover 19 según ellos la cifra
más alta en el mundo
así comenzó perú su proceso de
vacunación incluso el presidente de
sagasti ya fue inoculado también pero es
uno de los países más afectados por la
pandemia en la región de américa latina'
1.2 millones de casos han sido
confirmados y esto va acompañado con un
colapso hospitalario y falta de oxígeno
vamos a conocer más detalles con
francisco zacarías nuestro corresponsal
en la ciudad de lima la capital peruana
y comienzo por preguntarle francisco
detalles y el balance que hacen las
autoridades de esta primera semana de
vacunación de la puesta en marcha del
plan de inoculación allí en perú
el gobierno pero no movilizó a 35 puntos
de distribución en diferentes regiones
del perú a las 300.000 dosis de la
vacuna de sino farc contra kobe 19 según
el ministerio de salud ya han sido
inmunizados más de 32 mil peruanos en
esta primera etapa solo serán vacunados
el personal sanitario miembros de la
policía y las fuerzas armadas si bien el
gobierno del presidente francisco
sagasti estableció un plan de vacunación
esta primera etapa está caracterizado
por el desorden se han registrado
denuncias de exclusión a personal
sanitario que elabora en la denominada
primera línea de lucha contra el mortal
sharqat 2 algunos sindicatos de
trabajadores del sector salud afirman de
que no todos aquellos que elaboran en
las unidades de emergencias o en
cuidados intensivos de algunos
hospitales fueron incluidos en la nómina
de vacunación que había sido elaborada
por el ministerio de salud algunos
médicos y enfermeras se quejaban porque
ellos no los vacuna van y en su lugar
inoculaban la personal que pertenecen a
oficinas y áreas administrativas
francisco veíamos que había mucho
escepticismo por parte de los
o simplemente no creen en las vacunas
ahora que ya ha comenzado el plan de
vacunación y que esto ya está en marcha
ha cambiado la percepción de los
ciudadanos
existe un 48% de peruanos que se
resisten a ser vacunados ha habido mucha
polémica a través de las redes sociales
respecto a la vacuna contra el
coronavirus por eso muchos peruanos le
exigieron al presidente francisco
sagasti de ser el primero en ser
vacunado saggas y respondió al reclamo
de los peruanos y fue a vacunado en un
hospital militar tras esto se esperaba
que la población se decidiera a recibir
la inmunización pero en las últimas
horas en la ciudad de tarapoto ubicada
en la amazonía peruana una enfermera fue
hospitalizada tras ser vacunada esto
descendido nuevamente las alarmas con
comentarios de diverso calibre en las
redes sociales el ministerio de salud ha
informado que solamente se ha tratado de
una reacción adversa y que la enfermera
se encuentra estable el tiempo dirá si
esta situación terminó por inclinar la
balanza en la decisión de los peruanos
por decidirse a aceptar la vacuna o
negarse a ella
francisco mirando algo de información
oficial allí en perú el gobierno anunció
que va a recibir otras 700.000 dosis en
los próximos días
en esta oportunidad entonces estás dosis
para que el sector de la población van a
ser destinados
las 700.000 dosis que se espera lleguen
pronto forman parte de un millón de
dosis de scinopharm que han sido
designadas para aquellos peruanos que se
encuentran en la primera línea de
batalla contra el kobe 19 ellos son
médicos enfermeras técnicos en salud
miembros de la policía y las fuerzas
armadas una vez que se concluya con
ellos se comenzará a vacunar a los
trabajadores de áreas administrativas en
total son tres etapas del plan de
vacunación con el resto de dosis que
arriben se procederá a inocular a
aquellos que se encuentran en la segunda
fase que son adultos mayores de 60 años
después se van a vacunar a los
comprendidos en la fase 3 ellos son los
ciudadanos de 18 a 59 años el plan de
vacunación también comprende a los
extranjeros residentes en el país está
avanzando el plan de vacunación y siguen
dándose los contagios allí francisco
sobre todo en lima y en callado
recordemos entonces cuáles son las
restricciones y las medidas que se
mantienen en perú
el gobierno peruano ha extendido por 14
días más la cuarentena que está
focalizada en lima y en 32 provincias
que han sido catalogadas en alerta
extrema de contagio se ha ordenado que
solo una persona por cada familia pueda
salir a pie o en bicicleta para realizar
actividades especiales como comprar
alimentos o acudir al médico también se
prohíbe el uso de transporte público o
privado a los ciudadanos cuya labor no
sea esencial el toque de queda comienza
a regir a partir de las 6 de la tarde y
termina a las 6 de la mañana del día
siguiente el comercio solo se realiza
transacciones en línea y en el reparto
será por delivery los centros culturales
los museos lo mismo que bibliotecas
también están cerrados y los
restaurantes solo atenderán pedidos a
domicilio
francisco gracias por este reporte esta
actualización desde la ciudad de lima en
donde comenzó allí el plan de vacunación
en perú nos vamos ahora hasta argentina
que fue uno de los primeros países en
américa latina en recibir vacunas e
inocular las en su población hubo
también un poco de escepticismo en torno
a
solo le estaban apostando a la vacuna
sputnik bay de la que no había
información científica sobre su eficacia
y sobre su proceso de desarrollo el
gobierno presupuestó que para febrero
del 2021 tendría 20 millones de vacunas
en territorio argentino el país
recientemente acaba de pasar simplemente
el millón o espera recibirá el millón de
las cuales van a ser inoculadas en los
próximos días qué es lo que está pasando
cuáles son las demoras pues se lo vamos
a consultar a nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires- natalio con soy hola
natalio estamos viendo que este plan de
vacunación está avanzando pero muy
despacio y son muy pocas las provincias
que están teniendo acceso a las vacunas
y queríamos saber si esta segunda fase
ya va a ser para acceso a la población
normal porque hasta ahora las personas
vacunadas son solamente personas de
riesgo y de salud
si ya ha comenzado en argentina de la
vacunación de estos grupos que señalaban
se han dado cientos de miles de dosis
algunos ya recibieron las dos dosis de
las vacunas public ve que es por ahora
la que se está dando aquí en argentina
algunos una sola dosis hubo si alguna
algún problema con el calendario de
entrega de dosis de esta vacuna se
esperaba por parte del gobierno tener 5
millones de dosis en enero eso no
ocurrió y explicaron que se trató de
algún problema de producción desde rusia
si también dijeron que esperan que en
estas semanas se restablezca el
cronograma de entregas no es seguro que
los 20 millones que se esperaban
completar hacia marzo lleguen a tiempo
es algo que tendremos que ver por ahora
han llegado 820 mil dosis de esta vacuna
sputnik web argentina más 400.000 que
viajaron este viernes desde moscú a
buenos aires si los planes del gobierno
se concretan además se espera que las
próximas semanas lleguen cientos de mil
de dosis de la vacuna de oxford y
astrazéneca además de que más adelante
se sumen misiones de la del mecanismo
kóvacs de la organización mundial de la
salud y el gobierno además están
negociando con otros proveedores de
vacunas para tratar de acelerar esta
campaña de vacunación contra el
coronavirus en argentina natalia ahora
que la revista the lancet dio cierto
aval y un parte de tranquilidad sobre la
eficacia de la vacuna sputnik ve que
supera el 90 por ciento de eficacia ya
se redujo entonces esta desconfianza que
había entre algunos sectores médicos en
argentina y también entre algunos
ciudadanos por recibir una vacuna de la
que no se sabía su proceso de desarrollo
ni su efectividad ni cómo había sido el
desarrollo para llegar hasta ella
bueno no podemos decir que todo el mundo
esté convencido pero seguramente ayuda a
convencer a mucha gente algunos ya
estaban convencidos yo conozco en
médicos que se dieron la vacuna incluso
antes de que apareciera la publicación
en the lancet y ya estaban convencidos
de que era una buena decisión hacerlo
claro que ahora con esta convicción de
que es una vacuna eficiente y que
funciona y que es segura aparecen
también las presiones para que se sumen
más grupos a la vacunación hay gremios
por ejemplo el de transporte que pidió
ser priorizado seguramente esto es
posible que ocurra que algunos docentes
empiecen a sumarse a la vacunación ahora
que están por comenzar en estos próximos
días las clases en todo el país en forma
presencial en algunos colegios la
presencialidad será total en otros
colegios para asia el proyecto lleva a
estos grupos por ejemplo los docentes a
pedir que sean priorizados a la hora de
la vacunación por supuesto que grupos se
irán sumando de salud que está en
proceso de definición porque como
señalábamos
el retraso en la entrega de las vacunas
todavía está demorado este cronograma
este calendario este plan de vacunación
que está llevando adelante el gobierno
en argentina natal yo ya lo estaba
mencionando hace unos unas cuantas horas
llegó otra vez otro vuelo de aerolíneas
argentinas el tercero o cuarto que llega
ya a buenos aires esta vez con 400.000
dosis adicionales del sputnik
en este caso este lote para quien va a
ser destinado
si son 400.000 dosis que se suman a las
que ya llegaron al país pero el
calendario no no se ha modificado no se
han modificado las prioridades en
principio el gobierno nacional definió
primero totalmente al personal de salud
como prioritario luego a los adultos
mayores también a personas con riesgos
especiales en su salud a los grupos de
las fuerzas de seguridad por ejemplo
pero también es cierto que si bien la
nación ha definido este listado cada
provincia tiene la potestad de hacer
modificaciones parciales o totales a
estas prioridades y en algunos casos lo
están haciendo pero de nuevo todo
dependerá de la cantidad de vacunas que
logre recibir argentinas y el tiempo y
los plazos en los que la vaya recibiendo
natalia ustedes están en vacaciones de
verano muchas personas se fueron a las
playas del litoral argentino otras
personas a la sierra en la pampa qué
medidas se siguen manteniendo allí en
cuanto a restricciones a confinamiento y
autocuidado
bueno el gobierno extendió hasta fines
de febrero el que se llama
distanciamiento social que es una
especie de cuarentena suavizada que ya
se había implementado hace unos meses
mantiene restricciones a reuniones sobre
todo en espacios privados también
restringe el uso del transporte público
solo para trabajadores esenciales
mantienen cerrados cines teatros clubes
pero la realidad es que si se compara
con los meses más duros más restrictivos
de la cuarentena en 2020 estamos en una
situación bastante más cercana algo
parecido a la normalidad todavía por
supuesto no la normalidad pero a lo que
se le parece bastante más de hecho
estamos todavía en periodo de verano en
argentina de vacaciones y se ha visto
muchísimo movimiento turístico no como
antes de la cuarentena pero muchísimos
lugares del país donde había ocupación
casi total de las plazas hoteleras y eso
es algo que tiene un gusto a normalidad
más allá de las restricciones ahora
además
el comienzo de las clases y un comienzo
de clases que también suma un elemento
de normalidad pero también un elemento
de presión sobre la situación de la
pandemia porque existe el temor de que
con esto pueda con la circulación mayor
de personas tal vez acelerar el ritmo de
los contagios y en algún momento si eso
sucede y la vacunación no llega a darse
lo suficientemente rápido tal vez las
restricciones más duras vuelvan a
aparecer en argentino el regreso a
clases que sigue siendo todo un debate
natalio gracias por este reporte desde
la ciudad de buenos aires- mientras
tanto el proceso de vacunación en brásil
ha tenido sus complicaciones las
condiciones extremas de la amazonía como
el difícil acceso y las altas
temperaturas han dificultado la
inmunización en zonas remotas de esa
área norte del país a esto también hay
que añadirle el rápido aumento de los
casos de contagio debido a la nueva
variante local llamada precisamente
variante brasileña organizaciones
también algunas empresas y hasta los
ciudadanos se han unido para poder
garantizar la vacunación en el no
vacunaciones a contrarreloj en lancha a
las orillas del río negro cerca de
manaos más de 400 dirigentes de ongs y
empresas lanzaron una iniciativa para
ayudar a las autoridades brasileñas a
acelerar la campaña de vacunación
especialmente entre la población más
vulnerable los ancianos de las
comunidades ribereñas cuyo acceso a los
centros de salud se antoja casi
imposible y que a lo largo de la
historia ha sido diezmada por la
aparición de enfermedades la pandemia de
kobe 19 no ha sido menos
es fundamental la vacuna es la primera
gran barrera que tenemos ahora sabes
todo el mundo tiene que vacunarse la
vacunación tiene que ser masiva
desgraciadamente no hay muchas dosis
para algunos privilegiados como yo mira
qué ironía la vida como el movimiento
denominado unidos por la vacuna se dice
a político y busca asistir sobre todo a
dinamizar las tareas logísticas el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro blanco de
críticas por su gestión de la pandemia
empezó a inocular a sus 212 millones de
habitantes hace menos de un mes
el ambicioso objetivo de terminar las
vacunaciones antes de fines de
septiembre aunque los expertos señalan
que la campaña de vacunación duraría
cuatro años en brasil unidos por la
vacuna brindará apoyo tanto al gobierno
federal como a los 27 estados brasileños
y a los más de 5000 municipios
tuvimos cierta resistencia incluso en
relación con los ancianos con el apoyo
de nuestros médicos que vinieron a
visitarnos también dando consejos sobre
los beneficios de esta vacuna acabaron
cediendo y entonces la aceptación es muy
buenas acabaron siendo mi aceite sal
está siendo muy tumor brasil dispone
hasta ahora de 12 millones de dosis
aprobadas para su uso de emergencia del
laboratorio chino sinovac y astrazéneca
oxford hasta el momento el epicentro de
la pandemia en américa latina' tan sólo
ha inmunizado a 4 millones de brasileños
y seguimos en brasil la ciudad de río de
janeiro espera perdidas sin precedentes
ante la cancelación del emblemático
carnaval debido a la pandemia del cobe
19 esta celebración tuvo que ser
cancelada por primera vez en su historia
río de janeiro está vacía y se enfrenta
a la escasez no hay turistas los hoteles
operan a media marcha y el color del
carnaval se esconde bajo el gris asfalto
de las calles este año la pandemia mató
al carnaval del río
la fiesta más icónica de brasil y dejó
sin sustento a miles de cariocas que
viven del espectáculo
si no vais de carnaval no habrá carnaval
este año es duro y triste pero no habrá
carnaval pido a la gente que quisiera
asistir a fiestas o bailes de carnaval
no está permitido ni es legal no piensen
que es parte de la conversación porque
estas celebraciones no ocurrirán no hubo
claridad las escuelas de samba alma
corazón y vida del carnaval han tenido
que reducir drásticamente su personal a
ellos se suman infinidad de músicos y
bailarines así como comerciantes
artesanos diseñadores carpinteros
soldadores costureros y mecánicos muchos
se quedaron sin trabajo
publica la suscripción
voy a ver los desfiles de viradouro y a
disfrutar en casa no a intentar predecir
el futuro
tendré 10 meses de trabajo y lucharé por
el campeonato porque la escuela tendrá
un año maravilloso y llevaremos esa
energía al futuro y las consecuencias
económicas de la cancelación del
carnaval para evitar una mayor
propagación del cob y 19 se predicen
nefastas con pérdidas estimadas por la
patronal de los comerciantes en 509
millones de dólares el año pasado
2,1 millones de turistas de los cuales
cerca de 500.000 eran extranjeros
visitaron ríos durante la fiesta y
dejaron unos 717 millones de dólares en
tierra carioca
y a continuación otras noticias
destacadas de la semana comenzamos con
noticias para los viajeros la iata la
asociación internacional de transporte
aéreo se asoció con el gobierno de
panamá y con la aerolínea nacional copa
airlines para probar el ya está paz una
aplicación móvil que ayuda a los
pasajeros a gestionar sus viajes de
acuerdo con los requisitos
gubernamentales de cada país en cuanto a
pruebas de pcr y a procedimientos de
vacunación para más del primer país en
todo el continente americano en ensayar
este pasaporte digital y atención a los
viajeros suramericanos que van hacia el
reino unido ya habíamos hablado que
teníamos restricciones para ingresar
allí pues ahora el reino unido ha
impuesto más restricciones ahora es
necesario llevar no solamente la
documentación necesaria sino llevar
2.400 dólares en efectivo para pagar la
estadía de 10 días en un hotel para
pasar una cuarentena allí y también para
pagar sus pruebas de pcr en el sistema
británico de salud
y finalizamos en toronto en canadá en
donde las autoridades de esa ciudad
detectaron los primeros casos de la
variante de brasil y de sudáfrica del
coronavirus y advirtieron que esto
podría ser el inicio de una nueva
pandemia la alerta llega cuando varias
provincias canadienses también empezaron
a relajar algunas de las restricciones
impuestas para este momento la ciudad de
toronto ha dicho que debido al hallazgo
estas variantes no va a quitar las
restricciones impuestas
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos volvemos a
encontrar la próxima semana siga con la
programación de france 24
[Música]